nous sommes ici au sud de cramator ce
qui environ une trentaine de kilomètres
à l'ouest de darkmouth est-ce que vous
voyez ici c'est une clinique de médecine
familiale qui a été touchée pendant la
nuit par un missile et qui a dévasté
évidemment complètement détruit cette
clinique live qui a dévasté tout le
quartier regarder toutes les maisons
autour aucune de ces maisons n'est
intacte aujourd'hui et c'est presque un
miracle que personne n'a été blessé
évidemment les habitants ont été
réveillés pendant la nuit et ils ont eu
peur ils ont craint pour leur vie c'est
un dieu rappel de ce que c'est que de
vivre pour une population civile dans un
pays en guerre très près de la ligne de
front je peux vous écouter là-dessus
Tatiana l'infirmière qui travaille ici
qui a eu la peur de sa vie
[Musique]
a été très très active beaucoup de
détonations étaient entendues dans toute
la région des munitions incendiaires ont
même été utilisées autour de la ville de
constatininevica mais évidemment
aujourd'hui tous les jeux sont tournés
vers darkmouth une ville devenue symbole
de la résistance
ukrainienne mais une ville qui vit
peut-être ces derniers jours ces
dernières heures les
ukrainien en tout cas c'est clair sont
en train de préparer leur repli ils ont
même fait exploser un barrage pour
inonder une partie du territoire et
tenter de freiner tant possible
l'avancée des Russes ici Jean-François
Béland j'ai Radio-Canada au sud de
cravatorsk